see you all first of all I must
apologize just a little bit no sympathy
whatsoever from the two ladies or set
between the violins out like this okay
right you managed to see evacuation
should you be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building one by the nearest exit there's
one fire exit in this room if you need
to evacuate the glass door
bar escape staircase please hold on to
the handouts and place of stairs waiting
skip week if anyone is unable to use the
stairs would you please allow damage to
exit the room before they go to the fire
escape where they can be given
assistance
now assembly point will be in the public
car park outside in the city this week
please do not delay your evacuation for
any belongings please do not return to
the building and until people permission
to do so by staff please note this
meeting will be audio recorded and can I
please remind you to switch your mobiles
off or to other ones okay
not there was a time continuing
counselor Shore minutes of the meeting
held on the fourth of September copy
those are you happier
declarations of interest okay just to
remind you if your living comes up
police job so at that time matters
referred to the executive refer to the
executive and reports from other
committees there are no okay just before
we go on to the main item matters can I
remind members that there are parts of
both imports that are P and C we do have
members of the company here if you wish
to discuss those we will have to go into
P and C to discuss those parts of the
report so please be aware of that
okay the first item is item six being
linked Thank You chair and I sat in this
room observing the retailer on the 10th
of July little did I know that a few
months later over that should be back
here as the portfolio holder talking on
the projects but I am grateful to
colleagues from the 10th of July for
their representations because I have to
say that at that time Hobbes a little
concerned at the projected costs and I
didn't have a clear view of the vision
of what the big event looked like we
turn the clock on two or three months
and Here I am with a paper which has
been prepared by the strategic director
and her team which provides much for me
much better focus of the events where it
fits in within the discovere 2020
initiative within both Rockford and
within Essex and indeed at the national
agenda because there's all sorts of
things happening which are national
themes for 2020
and for me as a as a document it
provides really parity and focus of what
I believe now is exciting events that
should bring the heritage and traditions
of Rockford into focus and really
promote tourism culture and heritage and
the rich tapestry of our history which
profiteth has got to offer
as part of the theme of the discover
2020 project what I will say at this
stage and I'm not making a formal per
person at this stage but I will be
making a proposal that given the the
clarity on costs fought at the authority
I will be making a proposal to members
that we actually make this a free event
because I actually believe that it is so
worthwhile in terms of promoting our
heritage to all age groups within the
district and it is so important that we
do that and within the cost that was set
out I think it's not an unreasonable
reward for the out community to enjoy
the benefit so without further ado also
the strategic director to set out in
detail what the paper covers Thank You
councillor ting and members yes you'll
recall back in July that concerns were
raised in respected the geography of
policy Island and the reduced logistical
challenges of the transport plan which
which it was felt to raise issues of
cost and risk which were unsustainable
I've reconfigured the event and the
attractions which have been planned for
for Wallasey are now relocated to
Freight house and that is the freight
house site being the entire building the
car park and the green sward down to the
reservoir and that site as a consequence
removes a significant amount of risk and
cost in relation to those that transport
plan and it maintains an earlier
separate opening ceremony
once the iron to mark accounts and
significant investment in heritage
infrastructure on the RSPB reserve and
the totality of that means that the
budgets been reduced from fifty thousand
pounds for the two days down to fifteen
thousand without losing the quality of
the original plan if members are willing
to approve the matter this evening I
will then be in a position to go on and
submit and finalize and submit the event
management plan so that the secretary
fires recruit process can be initiated
and undertaken and then we can begin
publicity in earnest our plan is to to
launch as and to make tickets available
and just have go public in terms of
whipping up more interest around
Darwin's birthday on the 11th of
February
I'm 2020 and although the Beagle event
is they're kind of working tonight all
the colleagues and I've been using
internally we're going to be working
with a portfolio holder to craft those
publicity and that promotion with a view
to making a bit of a splash as we get in
here at the time I'd like to endorse the
comments that counsel was it would have
made I think that the big sticking point
for me was the cost and I think the the
proposal that counsel was ins indicated
he's about to make is it is a great step
forward and I think has the opportunity
to dramatically increase the footfall
and in turn hopefully make your job
easier in attracting people to want to
come to the site to advertise display
set up storm and so on and I think the
sort of money that we're talking about
represents a worthwhile amount for us to
invest in what what one of our core
objectives of promoting around your
mantra district
yeah again great was fine I think it's
good idea and we can make you late free
to the public can be quite after I would
say is they keep going in the big war
think it's a much bigger scope than the
people thing I think it's confusing when
people see the paperwork be prevent
interesting is people you should show
cheek more as the 2020
yes I think I think that in terms of
there's a safely the beagle if aliens
are kind of working title for the
purposes of managing it internally in
terms of external publicity certainly
not be working with council with me to
come up with a more inclusive talking
thank you very much I think one of the
things that that would attract me as far
as that's concerned is the fact of our
heritage in as much as that from a
British point of view we have always
been adventurous we've always to explore
to discover which is very much part of
what we have done in the past and I
believe whichever way you want to look
at it we will be needing to do that in
the future and I think that's a very
very important point that we should be
looking at is our heritage and our
ability to adapt to do things to be
adventurous to discover and surprise
those who have gone before us and take
their example going forward into the
future and I would like to also endorse
some of the things that councilman has
said in regard to people yeah thank you
how to grow the Commons have been made
before certainly I'm living in a
butchered area I think fantastic you've
been but a very I support council wasn't
in terms of making it accessible so all
families because what I'd hate to see
happen is that families can't afford to
actually attend an event like this the
right thing to do actually to make it
free to our visitings yeah i've cleaned
those women outside and ii actually a
great time
thank you Jesus
right so can I make a special thanks to
the GU director and her team put this
revised paper together thank you for
that and and if we can take the
amendment to be sooner and the amendment
I would suggest is that the entrance to
be free to the public to attend the
freight house for the beagle events say
that the beagle event may be a case that
in may be a case of changing it wasn't
that something that we were just talking
about that we have a legal it may the
night yes yes and you simply know at
this stage it just to add a little bit
of clarity to that the focus for
Rockford council is around illegal
events it is actually part of the 20
year of 2020 initiatives which a lot of
community groups parish councils are
buying into and I think possibly we need
to work on the PR side of projecting
that project but our project is centered
really about Darwin the bigger the event
and the history associated with that and
it will put in other things because
we're certainly used the phrase else
there's an opportunity to pull in other
ancillary things so that's why the
moment it's being referred to is the
thing that makes it is subsumed within
the overall 2020 commemorations it's
just a work event
do you have a second if you wanna okay
members any questions on the amendment
okay just one thing about that there's
two bits over two days I understand yes
the way you're saying is that the public
can come to the first day these days
private so so the freight house will be
available from midday on the Friday for
to enable set up their suggestion is
that if we can get sufficient corporate
sponsorship that there would be a
preview evening on the Friday before the
venue is open to the public on Saturday
and Sunday because we were asking people
to come along and display free of charge
and for example we would want to have
press a VIPs at the previous evening so
for example I have literally yesterday
received an email from the
great-great-great grandson of Charles
Darwin who has a model of HMS Beagle he
was prepared to come and display that
model and be present as at the at the
event and we would want a private press
event to enable sponsors and VIPs to
have a preview of the exhibition before
we open to the public
thank you thank you
okay first of all can we take a vote on
the members is everybody happy with the
image yes and going back to the
recommendations on page 6.1 like a month
pretty happy that take those on mess and
everybody happy to accept those items
sent the cow is on the disposable a
rainy Simon Thank You Jer I have to say
it's always one of the nice to be a
newly appointed portfolio holder would
actually be picking up on an issue which
I know has been rolling around for some
considerable time and I don't in any way
take the credit for the hard work that
has happened in the background but as
you say this is about disposal and off
of London Road Raley I think at this
stage I will ask the managing director
to talk us through the paper I do have a
few comments to make following that
presentation and so thank you Kevin yeah
I mean the council owns a piece of land
that runs from London Road to the
location of really sports and social
club that piece of land has been has
been part of a planning application that
was granted or resolved to be granted by
the council way back in February 2018
the principle access to the development
of 100
on the cycle timber Grove was intended
in that application to be accessed
through the the council's land the
council has been involved in extensive
negotiations with the landowners in
order to try and reach a conclusion
about the value of that land
unfortunately those negotiations were
not concluded and in the meantime the
prospective purchaser of the land
sanctuary Housing Association indicated
that they would be willing to negotiate
with the council to deal with the the
access as part of their overall
acquisition of the of the site for
development so the report that is before
the executive this evening now seeks to
bring to a conclusion those negotiations
there is a detailed confidential
appendix that seeks to provide
information to members about the
valuation that we've reached in terms of
the negotiation with sanctuary Housing
Association as the report says the value
that's been placed on the on the piece
of land is is 300,000 pounds I mean
members want to talk in more detail
about the evaluation issues that led us
to reach that conclusion and then we'll
blobs have to go into into P&C but
otherwise the report is that or the
recommendation is that the freedom of
interest is disposed of at the value of
300,000 to sanctuary Housing Association
thank you Jeff in terms of adding to
what the money director has said and
obviously I've had previous discussions
with officers on this and I do although
he's actually within the report I would
like to bring
this meeting that the agreement to sell
this piece of land has nothing to do
with any other section 106 agreements
which may be subsequently agreed and the
other condition that I've asked to make
sure remains some of these piece of mind
is that it is alluded to in here but
very strong the legal clauses are put in
to ensure that what's a district council
the utilities and any successive users
of that piece of land have full rights
of way because obviously we have
interests in the sports club and the
surrounding area and probably certainly
walk back from recorded thank you
thank you
well I would like to commend the
officers for the due diligence or work
they've done over this last 20 months
it's been a very difficult negotiation
and I would like to thank them for for
coming up with something that we can
actually use that we can take as a
recommendation going forward and say I
would like to thank them for the hard
work they put in over you know this last
20 months and you know going through all
the very difficult negotiations that
need to go through and all the legal
wrangles that had to come and we've come
to this point and I'm glad to see this
point I'm also glad to be able to see
the residents in Fitzroy house being
able to get their new property and being
able to move I think that's the most
important factor in this whole saga in
as much as that these very vulnerable
people will be able to move to be moved
into a new premises very very quickly
and so the whole process could be can
come to an end
satisfactorily I think they everybody
thank you yesterday without needing to
take us into the inn
pensee just for the record just like to
stress the contents of paragraph 3.6
that just state that the counselors
sought an independent opinion of its
value from more valuers as for the value
of I think that needs to be said yeah
not so clearly okay we have a
recommendation on page 7 21 1.1 I'll
read it out to the Creed's of the
disposal of the freehold interest of the
leg HD read on the attacks play for the
value of three hundred thousand pound to
sanctuary energy
is everybody in agreement rated rated
Thank You members that means we're
meeting to an end